you heard a Tony Montana Goodfellas
Godfather well what's usually associated
with this name big mafia new rock said
me our problems you know I don't know
what is the gene you know but from the
life I live I live bad life are you
proud of that no but you must must
breathe five times in the day I said
myself how can I pray five times they I
can go in the discotheque
I can shoot anybody more I can do
nothing
I can pray why to pray what is the pray
he said me if you want to help you go to
make rock here and after make your okay
I must you must prepared to everybody
don't go that way is the bad way if you
die in that way you go to the Jahannam
for the whole time assalamu alaikum how
you guys doing we're here in bosnia
meeting some unique individuals you
heard of Tony Montana Goodfellas
Godfather what we're gonna be talking
about that kind of gangster stuff some
of that mafia stuff all of those things
that unfortunately many people are
trying to chase that lifestyle but my
next guest he was in that lifestyle and
he got out of that lifestyle and we're
gonna hear some of those stories being
shot at almost killed shooting people to
finally waken up and trying humbly his
best to connect with his creator we're
gonna be with my brother
Elvis Kalman D on the D show don't go
anywhere
Salam alaikum brother how are you
alaikum Salam Halabi ricotta
so how do you how do you pronounce your
name again and this commanded when
people hear this name this last name
you're from Kosovo right yes I'm from
Kosovo from pale from pea okay so when
people from pea when they are from
Albania or Bosnia Serbia when they hear
this name my last name cuz kill Mandy
Cal Mandy when they see our kill Mandy
what's usually associated with this name
in the press and the media or just in
the average people big mafia in Europe
big mafia in in europe criminal drugs
and most violence I said so this is this
is what is associated with your last
name yes are you proud of that no why
but they know that because I'm not that
ok so now is this is this something that
but you were part of that you were you
were part of that in the past yes yeah
Billy's mom told me yes there really
smelly smoke problema or the Cosmo -
Cosmo miss mother Co the cupola smart
aleck please move away move adorable
boss no asthma doctor the local newbie
mafia she is Oliver Stone's racketeering
us resolution the specimen superstar
little mr. Tommy memo small van see mama
drew ganache is diverted drew drew a
character even a swim only problem at
all but an explosive are whatever puts a
new hotel go its leash not East Valley
Yanis mr. superstar li e anastomosis
apparently he Picasso is we're not try
then I'm over taco alley and now you got
a turf war this is like a turf war
yes they wanted to charge you taxes for
being and
yeah so you weren't having that huh were
you at that time you weren't practicing
Islam where there was no Islam in your
life did you even believe in God
no no tell us tell us get let us get in
your mind what what kind of thought
process that you were willing to die for
some cause right for the gangster cause
yeah tell us what what was in your
psyche numerous mutual Tama no reason -
she was some - this could take days
later the main urgency diminished
between demeanor story - she was so out
of it
thus they much para daters Fuji dusty
bride Angie with daughter
The Plough church that Oh chuckles oh he
was mrs. Roberta doc nice Ambu Putin
vida de três you hold a dubious unpaid
Mitaka too strongly no criminal Sequoyah
w-which chatter desk Odin I was at 400
you'll be apostate takashina Chester
Rudy Eugene that nice Ambu is far from
his nurse taste on the change does not
know it's missed on salmon or Amazon by
Ram Toto mr. Droog Aslam you know
socially Pena's it tell us you also
ended up in jail for some time yes yeah
what happened there well my friend this
is a shot here in Bosnia from that gang
from here and after one year he go out
and I make revenge for my friend and I
go to the coast of escape and after one
years in the course of one I escape
Kosovo police took me and I I go to the
jail I been punished
five five years and I took it for years
in the Kosovo jails so what part of your
life did you start thinking okay this is
enough because we know that this life
either ends up you being dead six five
ten whatever how many feet under the
ground right because there's always
someone more crazy the young guys are
coming up right we start getting older
and you got the young guys they just
watched Toni Matata right they just what
I was
same yeah Tony my turn out the guard fog
good my life is was the gun no god only
god we are going to shoot somebody to go
to the sadaqa in the same yada put some
to prove yourself hardly I want to prove
myself yeah I can shot everybody who
can't mean that
in the end you wanted the respect huh
yes how are the respect yes but I get it
you get it I get it that power in that
respect I have some problem now when I
go with my friends to same objects in
the Sarajevo
everybody is afraid but nobody Fred from
Florida for the human being we must
fight it all from Allah Oh beautiful now
that's that's the way to talk to be
fearful and to love the one who created
you so at what point in your life now
did you start thinking hold on man this
is enough I'm gonna end up in jail for
life forever
or I'm gonna end up dead when did you
start thinking there's got to be more to
life what's my purpose in life when did
this happen that now you started to
really think in 2007 I I thought I was
to think my friend is coming I have some
problem with the jinn you know he said
me you are problems you know I don't
know what is the gene you know but from
the life I live I live bad life no
normally you have the jinn after I lost
I learned for the gene for the that that
vault of the gene and have that problem
he said me if you want to help you go to
make rook here and after me okay I must
you must must breathe five times in the
day I said in myself how can I pray five
times day I can go in the discotheque I
can shoot anybody more I can do nothing
I can pray why to pray what is the pray
and I go thinking about that what he say
my brother brother he's from tsarevo
kala nag rod is that was to me preacher
today Tommy I think in a thinking a
thinking and I said to my ex-wife I want
to play
he look at me what yes I said from
tonight I want to play and hundred I
want to play I purchase on the Hunnam
Advaita they said man he Allah
alhamdulillah Allah wear suits he widows
and the new Sunni coochie he will never
tell E me outta Akashi with the
initiative that she must fume that he
started a la condición hora de la Mancha
model Guevara masses for the request
mirada's Ronald la donna Sawa Sawa toga
redeem Oh redeem or semi dobra Lucia del
upon SMS subbu
bhisma crashing upon openness and grace
Roboto Nirmala dimitra's the mrs. Finley
the tortoise am Raju proton rivet that a
proportion sarcoma coconut important
that tenido Babu is not the good way I'm
prepared to everybody
don't go that way is the bad way if you
die in that way you go to the Jahannam
for the all time hamdullah
allah give me the Islam give me the
Hamas I'm prayed of that he gave me why
he gave me I'd be so bad but he give me
than a mosque and I ask myself so many
time why Allah he take me to play the
namaz I don't know I don't know that as
for now
it's a gift it's definitely a gift and
we can't can't take it for granted and
do you feel sometimes you're in between
two worlds because now you're leaving
that life you've left that life but now
have you made enemies along the way and
then sometimes they try to pull you back
in and now Islam it humbles you it makes
you a better human being you don't want
to hurt nobody you don't even want to
hurt an ant no if I think to hurt
somebody
I know I'm gonna answer to Allah for the
further but data if I do before I don't
think I hurt everybody I don't care for
nothing but now if I want to do
something bad I know I have Hawaii
watching me and I know I gonna answer
what for what I do I'm gonna answer to
Allah
yeah you got you got you got even a
bigger responsibility now because you
have everyone else who's watching now
and they're rooting for you to be better
you know to stay to stay because it's a
struggle it is a struggle to stay on the
right way because there's all these
temptations all these things so you had
you talked about you had the villas you
had the car and see everything villus
cuz I didn't I don't need nothing I
don't only want to be Allah yeah yeah
have you had a chance an opportunity for
some people that are still in that
lifestyle to have a positive influence
to pull them out from the Mafia gangster
so-called lifestyle have you had a
chance to be I have so much I don't give
all my friends I know nobody take drugs
nobody take alcohol handle about me know
any mechanism only drove me alchemists
and pure Islam nikinike
to me a lot of emotions listen listen
opinion is Ramiro Ali is Canada Ahmad
rose to leadership in the state
regulator
Kokomo go Powe Savannah stamp over Stoke
ominous feat when you swim I drove a
Cubano como de de de Zarate mr. Koerner
the Buddha the Buddhist Lama Dasaratha
wahoo
the Narada toaster strudels with the PU
dusted Ruggerio to many people's make
truck and Sarah was 99% we go to her out
after after that everybody takes drugs
it's so so so bad I I don't I don't like
that what why do you think that is why
do you think I mean that people are
turning more towards you see that you
know people are turning to so many bad
things to drugs to gangs to violet why
why do you think you know people instead
you have you have this other good way
why you why you think people are more
gravitating towards deuced for gift
schemes to do just a cups your friends
friends old friends if you if my friends
take drugs he take drugs he takes it you
make scoop in Arizona yeah one does the
drug in reduced virtual lock so that
interest vanished I assume a protrusion
the severity law
demo talk jitesh them in awesome remove
our brain approximate cost of apado
busty more samples area more puts us on
the road puts awesome is out on I'll do
the first honest totally phenomenal and
they took gee what an image to
proportion seocho-gu do that IG what
news even dramatic its erotic Spadaro
sis veteran assist for you so there you
have it thank you for for sharing their
with us from being in that gangster
mafioso lifestyle being in shootouts
until now realizing what the purpose of
life is and then now making such that
calling upon the creator and trying your
best
we're all human beings and we shot fall
short many times but like I'd like to
tell people is that as long as your goal
is to work towards becoming a better
human being and you establish a
connection with the creator of the human
being then in sha allah there is hope
there is hope and I'm really happy that
you decided to turn your life around I
can understand because I was also a part
of that lifestyle and it's nothing good
there's no height in it and when you
live in purpose pleasing your Creator
and you let your striving for the GPS
Jenna that's life made the crater
continue to bless you I mean there's an
I spent some time with seasonality
alaikum Salaam